(gentle music)
- [Narrator] A series of events
called the menstrual cycle
happens about once every month
to prepare a woman's body for pregnancy.
Changing levels of natural
chemicals in the bloodstream
called hormones control these events.
The reproductive organs affected
by these hormones include the vagina,
cervix, uterus,
fallopian tubes, and ovaries.
The ovaries produce two main hormones
called estrogen and progesterone.
As the level of estrogen begins to rise,
it causes the normally thick mucus
inside the cervix to thin out.
Estrogen also triggers other hormones
to cause one of the
ovaries to release an egg.
This process is called ovulation.
If a woman has sex during this time,
a man's reproductive cells, called sperm,
can pass through the thinner
mucus to fertilize an egg.
In the uterus, estrogen
causes the lining to thicken,
which prepares it to
receive a fertilized egg.
Rising progesterone levels
cause glands in the lining
to release fluid that
feeds the fertilized egg.
Progesterone also causes
the thinned-out mucus
in the cervix to become thick again,
which prevents sperm from passing through.
If an egg hasn't been fertilized,
the levels of both estrogen
and progesterone begin to fall.
This drop in hormone
levels causes menstruation,
a process where the uterus
sheds its inner tissue lining
and blood through the vagina.
An intrauterine device, or IUD,
is a birth control method
consisting of a soft,
flexible T-shaped device with
a thin string on the end.
There are two types of
intrauterine devices:
hormonal IUDs and a copper IUD.
To prevent pregnancy,
a doctor places an IUD
inside a woman's uterus
with the string hanging
down inside her vagina.
Both types of IUD cause mild inflammation
of the uterine lining,
which releases immune cells
and chemicals that kill sperm.
Hormonal IUDs also
contain a synthetic type
of progesterone called levonorgestrel.
Levonorgestrel mainly prevents pregnancy
by thickening the mucus inside the cervix,
which prevents sperm
from entering the uterus.
It also prevents the uterine
lining from thickening
so it is less likely to
receive a fertilized egg.
About a month after inserting an IUD,
the doctor may schedule an exam
to make sure it is still in place.
The doctor may also teach the woman
how to check her IUD between visits
by feeling for the
string inside the vagina.
Depending on the type,
an IUD can be left in
place for 3 to 10 years.
Women can have their doctor
remove an IUD at any time
for any reason, including
the desire to have children.
An intrauterine device, or IUD,
is one of the most effective
methods of birth control.
IUDs are over 99% effective
at preventing pregnancy.
This means that less
than 1 out of 100 women
will become pregnant each
year if they use an IUD
and check it regularly
for correct placement.
However, IUDs are only about 97% effective
if not checked for correct placement.
For more information on
any type of birth control,
talk to your doctor.